ouverture demain du 49ème festival de
cannes avec un soupçon de provocation
son grand prêtre gilles jacob bas
programmé pour la soirée de clôture un
film intitulé flirte avec le désastre et
pour l'ouverture demain soir ridicule
ridicule le dernier film de patrice
leconte qui pour la première fois qu'ils
te 20e siècle les emmène le spectateur à
versailles à la cour de louis saez avant
de retrouver nos invités en direct de
cannes patrice leconte et fanny ardant
reportage de pascal deschamps et maryse
richard sur ce film au titre étrange à
exhiber leurs la moquerie exemple un
discours ridicule nul doute qu'après le
film le mot ridicule n'aura plus tout à
fait le même sens car à cause de ces
moqueries il est une époque d amour et
c'était à la cour de versailles avant la
révolution autour du roi
les privilégiés n'avait rien de mieux à
faire que subit liés les uns les autres
l'esprit était une âme ceux qui en
avaient été bien vu les autres
c'est dans ce climat que débarque un
jour un jeune provincial il voudrait
convaincre louis saez d'assécher les
marais de sa province où meurent chaque
jour à cause des fièvres des dizaines de
paysans mais pour avoir une chance de
rencontrer le roi il devra lui aussi se
plier aux règles de ce jeu cruel qui
sera la prochaine victime qui recevra en
pleine face un trait si spirituelle une
famille tombera dans la précarité vous
il ya un nate mission et même je dirais
historique qui est absolument
fantastique dans skins c'est à dire que
en lisant le scénario on ne peut qu on
se dit c'est formidable c'est un film
18e et pourtant qu'est ce que ça comme
écho en moi aujourd'hui quoi demain des
enfants de chez moi vont mourir ils
m'auront de ce ridicule qui met le but
aujourd'hui
vous enviez d'esprit mordant de monsieur
de voltaire le grand homme aurait pleuré
lui car il était d'une ridicule
sensibilité aux malheurs humains
patrice leconte nous raconte l'histoire
de privilégiés qui dissimulaient leur
peur derrière des masques des bons mots
les privilégiés dont ce n'est pas le
ridicule qui a provoqué la chute mais
l'absence de sensibilité comme alors les
autres le temps est à l'orage sur cannes
et nos invités se sont mises à l'abri
fanny ardant patrice leconte bonsoir
patrice leconte disons le tout de suite
ridicule ce n'est pas un bon film c'est
un film somptueux cruel brillant drôle
et tout à fait émouvant un rire grinçant
je le pense vraiment alors à l'époque
lévis était sans conséquence mais le
ridicule tue est en effet le ridicule
tuait mais vous mais je suis un petit
coup de pompe
démarrant comme ça votre phrase j'ai été
saisi merci j'ai que j'ai cru que vous
alliez dire ce n'est pas un bon film
c'est un film ridicule auquel cas
j'aurais quitté le salon dans lequel
nous sommes
c'est vrai que de nos jours le ridicule
ne tue plus et heureusement parce que
sinon ce serait une hécatombe au 18e ce
n'était pas une hécatombe il s'en
fallait de pas beaucoup parce que sur ce
grand navire qui sombre et qui était la
cour de louis saez le le le ridicule et
l esprit est étaient les armes les plus
les plus tranchantes et les plus
violentes utilisées à la cour donc le
ridicule tue et en effet alors il
fallait faire assaut d'esprit mais par
contre les calembours été très mal vu si
je vous avais dit le compte est bon la
jory tu es ridicule et six jeunes
avaient répondu comment comme common
ratio de points mais effectivement ça
aurait été un petit peu limité comme et
donc on aurait été disgracié si on avait
vécu à l'époque de louis saez certains
seraient alors donc je je je vous je
vous dis plutôt comment allez-vous y yo
de poils
certains seront peut-être un parallèle
avec les liaisons dangereuses mais vous
vous avez un regard beaucoup plus tendre
beaucoup moins cynique sur ses moeurs
oui enfin j'espère ne pas être cynique
en effet un parce que le cynisme c'est
assez terrible mais au fond de moi même
je sais que le film tout en étant ce
souriant et poudrée et est un film qui
qui est au fond de son âme assez assez
noir comme comme était assez noir les
courtisans à versailles à l'époque alors
je sais pas si film et cynique non je ne
le souhaite pas oui on est on est assez
loin on est même très très loin un des
grands du que votre dernier film et des
bronzés vos premiers films est ce que
vous vous referiez maintenant un film du
style des bronzés non parce que si vingt
ans après je faisais les bronzés qui est
un film que j'ai adoré faire ça voudrait
dire que je jouais pas beaucoup changé
ni évolué je sais pas si j'ai beaucoup
changé
je continue à m'amuser à faire des tas
de choses différentes à à prendre un
malin plaisir être un cinéaste
buissonniers mai mais je ne pourrais pas
faire et bronzé aujourd'hui parce que
parce que parce que tout change nous
nous changeons mais j'ai chez j'ai adoré
faire les bronzés et vous savez chez
très embarrassée parce que l'on peut en
fait je crois que j'ai aimé
passionnément faire tous les films que
j'ai faits à l'arrivée il y en a qui qui
ont été réussis avec plus ou moins de
bonheur un j'en suis conscient en tant
pis pour moi mais au moment où j'ai fait
mes films j'ai adoré les faire et est ce
ce ridicule là qui nous occupe
aujourd'hui est un est un film que
j'aime passionnément ce qui semble
totalement immodeste mais tant pis pour
moi finir dont vous avez un très très
beau rôle de comtesse une femme
ambitieuse intrigante mais aussi très
très fragile
alors c'est encore une fois un très très
beau rôle et encore une fois on est
assez loin de douce votre votre
avant-dernier film c'est ça ce qui
advient dans les actrices ce que vient
de dire patrice leconte c'est que on
endosse des personnalités différentes en
doses des rôles différents mais
finalement ce qui reste intacte c'est le
plaisir de les faire alors
c'est vrai que j'aime et jouer et va de
douce et que j'ai tout de suite
après et s'est trouvée par les
circonstances de temps que j'ai tout de
suite enchaîné avec la comtesse de
blagnac
qu'est ce qui vous assure qu'est ce qui
vous a séduit justement particulièrement
dans le scénario qui est extrêmement
brillant justement ce côté brillant ce
côté le langage qui servait de suspense
la structure les personnages qui
n'étaient tout pas tous blancs est tout
noir mais les gens avec leur côté leur
côté ridicule et leur côté complètement
humains leur fragilité leur force leur
côté ambiguë et j'aime et que tout d'un
coup le langage de vienne comme une arme
un peu comme au théâtre jusqu'à présent
ne voyais ça que marivaux ou jeu des
relais de laclos et tout d'un coup au
cinéma on avait la possibilité d'avoir
des sentiments humains très humain avec
une langue magnifique
est-ce que vous avez déjà monté les les
grandes marches de cannes
j'avais déjà monté les marches pour un
film italien
la famille est un film de margarethe von
trotta mais à chaque fois c'est une
émotion nouvelle parce que le film est
différent les gens avec qui on l'a fait
son différent alors pour re commun alors
il n'y a pas eu de film france et palme
d'or à cannes depuis 87 alors est ce que
l'un et l'autre dans vos rêves les plus
fous vous imaginez que ridicule puisse
avoir la palme d'or en croisant les
doigts
oui comme vous dites dans les rêves les
plus fous mais vraiment les plus fortes
et je l'espérais en tout cas merci bravo
encore une fois c'est un film tout à
fait bruissant remarquable et je signale
qui sort en salles dès demain donc les
français et les françaises qui ne sont
pas à cannes auront le plaisir de
découvrir ridicule dès demain une petite
heure